the decision servers were restarted
after a period of downtime on March 12
and Ubisoft have implemented a couple of
changes the latest patch has disabled
the trained talent as Ubisoft are
concerned it could provide an unfair
advantage in endgame content and in the
dark zone the trains talent enables
critical hits to increase your signature
skill resource by five percent which is
a pretty beefy bonus if you're playing
the division and know what all those
words mean for example with an SMG it
would be possible to keep your signature
skill up constantly which can increase
team damage and critical chance or
damage resistance and speed depending on
your signature skill of choice so the
moment the talent will still be visible
in weapon descriptions but it will have
no effect until a further update which
will replace it the patch also made
changes to the general balancing of
experience gained and drop rates for
items and currency for example the
number of endgame Phoenix credits
dropped from elite enemies which are
required to obtain high end gear was
reduced from around ten to thirty two
one two three four more update info and
everything else there is to know about
the division stay tuned to GameSpot's